- They knew that this bill
didn't ban books, okay?
'Cause we had already
discussed that
the day before in
the rules committee,
before the debate came
to the whole House.
They knew it didn't ban books,
but they went down there
and said it anyways,
because they knew a lot
of their constituents
wouldn't do the due
diligence to find that.
- Yeah, and stated a
little bit differently,
the bill does
nothing to do that.
What it does do is
empower parents, and
they come in and go,
"Well, you're just gonna
empower this mob to go after."
Well, hold on a second.
There are books
that I don't want to be
in the school library.
Let me be perfectly clear.
The question is which library,
elementary, high school?
And then parents should be
able to have the say there.
That's literally
all this bill did,
was say parents should
be able to know.
(curious pop music)
- Dave Rubin, Thomas
Massie, Chip Roy.
How was that for an intro?
- Sounds good to me.
- Nailed it.
- Solid, this is it.
This is the end of
my little DC tour.
I'm finishing up with you guys.
Something about
this giant table.
I feel like this could end
both of your careers right now.
- You saved the best for last.
- You guys are on
trial right now.
All right, Thomas, I
gotta start with you,
because everyone's
gonna be wondering
about that thing right there.
You have the debt
clock on your lapel.
- He bought me one, I'm
still waiting on it.
- [Dave] Yeah, where's yours?
- You know, some people
have a pacemaker up here,
a lot of these old senators.
I've got an anxiety maker.
I'm trying to make
their hearts skip beats,
and become concerned
by looking at the debt
increasing each day.
I wrote the software in here.
I made the case.
I've got some 3D printed
ones I'm working on
so Chip Roy can have a copy.
But it goes to the treasury's
website once a day,
gets the actual
debt to the penny,
and then makes its best guess
based on the average debt
per second over the last year
about what the debt is
at this very moment.
- I'm gonna guess that, when
you're back home in Kentucky,
or, I should say Kentucky
and Texas, of course,
when you're back
home in Kentucky,
people probably dig it.
You come here and
everyone's like,
"Could you put that thing away?"
Little bit of that?
- The Democrats, I had one
in an elevator look at it
and say, "Is that
a doomsday clock?"
And I said, "Yes, ma'am, it is."
- Well, they're always
escalating that situation.
So you guys are on the
freedom side of things,
I would say.
You're on what I
would generally call
the more libertarian side,
freedom side of things.
I sense, after three days here,
that that really
is the direction
that the Republican
party is going in.
Do you agree with that or
am I just being pollyannish?
- I mean, I'll say that
I think that, certainly,
there is more of an
appetite for that
among a larger block of
the Republican party.
That doesn't necessarily mean
that's the overall direction.
We still have a lot of people
we've gotta get there, right?
There is still an
enormous dominance
of what I would call the
war caucus in this town,
and I say that as someone
who, child of the eighties,
and very much believe in
a very strong military.
Use sparingly but forcefully.
But we've got a kind of
stranglehold on this place
of the way we've
always done things,
and part of the issue here with
freedom is reminding people
why we have a limited
government of diffused powers
and why that's important
for preserving and
protecting our rights.
Nothing illuminated
that more than COVID.
Nothing illuminated the
dangers with centralizing power
and giving power to a handful
of cronies like Anthony Fauci
than what we just witnessed.
Thomas has been one of
the leaders on that,
along with Rand Paul.
I've tried to help, and others,
but we've got to
continue to elevate that.
There is an increased
appetite for it, but, in part,
because these
people in Washington
respond to their constituents,
there's a lot of Americans
who want us to preserve
and protect liberty.
- Let's be honest.
Let's be honest, though.
The fight that happened
the first week of January
over who would be the next
speaker was very consequential.
And a lot of people say,
"Oh, that looked so bad.
The Republican party
was in disarray."
No, that is how it's
supposed to work.
We're not supposed to have
all these backroom deals
and everything's baked.
And what came out of
that is, actually,
Chip Roy and I ended up
on the rules committee,
along with Ralph Norman.
So, conservatives, the
people who are most likely
to advocate for freedom
through legislation,
have a blocking position
on every bill that
comes to the floor now.
And also, for the first time
since I've been in Congress,
we're actually imposing
time to read the bills.
Here we are, three
months into this session,
and every bill that's
come to the floor,
you've had 72 hours to read.
Now, 72 hours, I know
people back home are like,
"There's not time to
read a bill in 72 hours."
- But it's better
than 72 minutes.
- Yeah, 72 minutes was the norm.
- Right, right.
- And the other
thing is 72 hours
gives people back home time
to read about it in the news
and then call the
other congressman.
So it's a heads up.
You know, you could
give our colleagues
a year to read a bill
and some of them are
not gonna read it,
or they could read
it, know what's in it,
know it's bad, and
still vote for it.
What's important is
the American people
have a chance in the news cycle
to find out what's
going on up here,
call their congressman,
and influence it.
- So to that point, I sat
down with Speaker McCarthy
at the Capitol yesterday,
and I sensed, actually, now,
maybe it wasn't when you
guys were in the fight,
that he kind of is
happy with the results.
I think he does feel like
maybe it empowered him a
little bit by you guys pushing.
Do you think that's fair?
- Look, I think that's fair.
I mean, of course he's
happy with the results
'cause he got to be speaker.
- He did get the gig.
It was a messy couple days.
- But in fairness
to Kevin, right,
I mean yesterday
he sent a letter
to the President of
the United States
detailing some
spending restraint
that a lot of us have
been pushing for.
He did uphold his
end of the bargain
in ensuring that several of
us got on the rules committee,
that we have more conservatives
on the appropriations
committee and other committees,
that we've been adhering
to a number of the rules
that we had asked
for back in December.
So all of that's good,
and I think, when that happens,
there's a unity that
builds around that.
Now, getting to 218
on anything is hard,
and you gotta only lose
four, five, six guys or gals
and it's difficult, but, look,
I think what we saw
coming out of January
was a renewed spirit that,
when some people stand
up on what they believe,
you can prove that the
sky's not gonna fall.
You can have 435 people in
the chamber debating stuff
and actually move the needle,
rather than just kind of
retreating to your corners
doing press conferences
and walking away.
And I think we showed that,
and I think Kevin's the
beneficiary of that.
- Yeah, let me give an example
of how the new system
actually works out for Kevin.
So, to get the majority,
he went out and did
a lot of campaigning,
and one of his signature issues
that a lot of people care about
is reclaiming our schools,
basically letting parents know
what their kids are learning.
And so, there was a bill
that was coming to the floor,
HR5, that would impose
a requirement on
every school system
in the United States that
you publish your curriculum
and the list of the books
that are in your library,
so parents-
- Real Fascist stuff,
if you listen to AOC,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Well, believe it or
not, Chip Roy and I
had a small issue
with that bill,
which a lot of members
of our conference did.
We were like, well, you know,
we prefer the Department of
Education doesn't even exist.
So the question, like, if by
reforming it or directing it,
are we violating our
principle of federalism
and leaving things
up to the states?
And so, they asked me,
"Is there any way you
could vote for this bill?"
And I said, "Yeah, if we
have an amendment on the bill
that eliminates the
Department of Education."
If I can show a
preference legislatively
through my votes on the floor,
not just say something
on a website,
that my preference is to
get rid of this department
rather than reform it, I
could vote for the final bill,
regardless of how it turns out.
Well, and Chip was the same way.
He said-
- I was able to offer
some amendments that
would require dollars
to be block granted
to the states,
which would be sort
of the next step.
Like, I favor abolishing it,
but if you can't do that,
can we at least just
give it to the states
and let them decide?
And if you can't do that,
can we at least let the dollars
eventually get to the parents
to be able to just
use themselves?
So we got a vote on all
three of those amendments.
- And what surprised me is Kevin
voted to remove all the power
from the Federal
Department of Education,
to micromanage elementary
and secondary education.
So, for the first time
since Jimmy Carter
set up this Department
of Education
as a reelection
ploy that failed,
we had a referendum in the
House of Representatives
on whether they
should exist or not
in our schools back home.
And Kevin joined us on saying,
"No, they shouldn't.
Give it back to the schools."
- So this might sound
sort of amateur hour,
but the department, obviously,
is still going to exist,
but it just won't
have authorization
when it comes to
these types of issues.
- And let me be clear, before
everybody gets real excited.
Our amendments didn't pass.
- Right.
- But we still voted
for the final bill,
because we got a chance to
put everybody on record,
and now people
back home can say,
"Would I rather
have a congressman
that wants to take
the federal government
out of my kids' education,
or a congressman who wants
the federal government?"
- Well, and one
final point on that,
to your point, so
what did we pass?
We passed legislation,
as Thomas described,
that empowers parents
to know what their
kids are being taught.
We put out in the record a
whole bunch of garbage books
with all sorts of total
smut and ridiculous things
that were in libraries
and in curriculum,
and we were demonstrating that.
- That's the underlying bill.
- And that's the
underlying bill.
But for me to get comfortable
with federal power
being used to go tell a
local school district,
you're gonna require parents
to be able to see this stuff.
I needed to demonstrate
that my personal preference
is to get the feds out
of it all together.
But in the absence
of that, then, yeah,
a parent ought to have a right
to at least know how these
dollars are being used
and what's being
taught to their kids.
And so, I think getting
that series of votes,
restoring the way things work,
which is a part
of that agreement,
empowered Kevin and empowered
us to come together.
- Yeah, just to cap all that,
that bill probably
would've failed.
- [Dave] Correct.
- And Kevin, one of
his major initiatives
that he campaigned on
wouldn't have been able
to pass in a majority.
- If we don't pick the rules.
- If we didn't have,
if we didn't help him
put into the process
an ability for conservatives
to express their preferences.
- So was the calculation
by you guys that,
yes, you would prefer that
the federal government
not do anything, but not
every state is going to do
what perhaps Texas and
Kentucky and certainly Florida,
Iowa, Arkansas, a couple other
states are doing right now?
So it was sort of your only
way, in essence, right?
'Cause Cali is never gonna
do this sort of thing,
New York, et cetera.
- Well, I mean, again, and going
back to preferences, right?
I would rather,
even though I think
what California does is insane,
I would rather just get
the feds out of it and say,
"If you wanna be in insane
in California, go ahead.
But don't mess with
my kids in Texas
or don't mess with
the kids in Kentucky."
But in the absence of that,
if we're going to,
as we do currently,
have federal dollars flow,
I think it is within reason
of me being able to say
I would prefer
this other outcome,
to be able to go
in and say that,
"Yeah, parents have a right."
And, frankly, even in
Texas and Kentucky,
it's not like every
parent in Texas
knows exactly what's going on.
So where those federal
dollars are flowing.
Now, they'll have a
little bit more ability
to push for that.
- So, when you guys
see AOC afterwards,
talk about how this bill was
basically passed by fascists
and it's like, man, she
needs some better education,
'cause she doesn't
know what it means.
Or Hakeem Jeffries, you know,
they don't want to teach
about the Holocaust.
I mean, these were the responses
you got out of these guys.
I've asked this to every
Republican I've sat down with
for the last three days,
are you talking to these
guys in the back rooms,
going, "What the hell
are you talking about?
You know that's not legit."
- I mean, in the rules
committee, we debated this,
and Chip was right to point out,
they knew that this bill
didn't ban books, okay?
'Cause we had already
discussed that
the day before in
the rules committee,
before the debate came
to the whole House.
They knew it didn't ban books,
but they went down there
and said it anyways
because they knew a lot
of their constituents
wouldn't do the due
diligence to find that.
- Yeah, and stated a
little bit differently,
the bill does
nothing to do that.
What it does do is empower
parents and they come in and go,
"Well you're just gonna
empower this mob to go after."
Well, hold on a second.
There are books
that I don't want to be
in the school library.
Let me be perfectly clear.
The question is which library,
elementary, high school?
And then parents should be
able to have the say there.
That's literally
all this bill did,
was say parents should
be able to know.
- Did you guys see on TV,
was it about a week ago?
DeSantis is going through the
books that they've removed.
It's basically two books that
were pretty much pornographic,
and the media, the mainstream
media, had to cut away
because they can't show
pornography on ABC.
- That's funny.
- I pulled up one of those books
in the committee
that I was sitting on
where we had some witnesses,
and I was starting to
show, and I had to stop.
I showed the cover,
and then I opened it.
I was like, "I can't show this."
I literally couldn't
put it on CSPAN.
And that's the kind of thing
the government's saying.
- But it can be third grade.
- But they wanted to say
that they were removing Clemente
and Rosa Parks, all false.
Those books were
left on the shelves
or they were reviewed
as part of a process
and then put back on the
shelves, and that's the truth.
- By the way, they don't
read the bills we vote on.
I've read a few of their bills.
I've read The Green New Deal,
because it's only 14 pages.
And when I got done with it,
I realized why
it's only 14 pages.
There's only 64 crayons
in that big box.
- That's good.
(all laugh)
I saw it comment,
I saw it coming.
Is the difference
between Republicans
and Democrats right now sort
of as wide as you've ever seen
in your how many
years now in Congress?
- 10 1/2 for me.
How many for you?
- Yeah, I'm in my third
term, so four and change.
- So is that difference
wider than ever right now?
- It's gotten wider.
There were some moderate
Democrats when I first got here.
They kind of just finally
all got washed out here.
Through attrition,
they were going down.
But I don't blame AOC
for her positions.
I really don't.
I blame the people
that voted for her.
What you see here,
the division you see,
it truly is, and people may
not like when I say this,
it's a reflection of the
American voters' preferences.
And I think the country's
become more polarized,
and that's why you see
Congress more polarized.
- Yeah, if you
look at, right now,
there are places
in the northeast
or in certain sectors
of this country
where the people
are still masked.
I mean, you flip on the
NBC control room, right?
The control room, they're
all sitting there in masks.
Good grief, man,
like four years ago.
We weren't wearing
masks in Texas.
I went out to Lakey,
Texas, which I represent,
which is about two and a
half hours from my house,
and went out to, they
were doing goat roping
and it was a Labor
Day weekend in 2020.
Of course, the northeast
elites and all that stuff,
I mean, they were
cowering in their corners
and hiding and masked up.
These guys were
all out, you know,
the kids and everybody
were out in the rodeo
and they're roping goats,
and we were all getting together
and having food and dinner.
It was totally different worlds,
two different worlds, truly.
And that still exists today,
that divide, that difference,
that different view about
how you do these things,
and I think that is reflected
in the representatives
in Washington.
- Which is why we need more
solutions that are state-based
rather than federal.
- Correct.
You have to be able to
agree to disagree, right?
I mean, the reason I
believe in federalism
and the reason I hedged a bet
on the parents' rights bill
and wanted to go, well,
because all things being equal,
the only way this
republic survives
is if we can literally
agree to disagree
under our federal system.
If we're gonna tell
each other what to do,
it's going to break us apart,
and that's what we've gotta
figure out how to resolve.
- Is that really the fight
more than anything else?
Because it seems to me
that the red states,
and you guys know, I lived in
Cali and now I'm in Florida,
I feel like I live in
a different country.
But it seems to me
that the blue states
will never stop coming
for the red states.
The red states, I think,
could, for the most part,
be like, "Hey, we're just gonna
take care of our business,
and that's it."
But the blue states are not
gonna leave well enough alone,
and I sense that's what
is a big oncoming fight.
What do you think?
- Yeah, I mean, I
certainly think that's been
the direction things have
been going for a while.
I mean, certainly,
whether it's the kind
of DEI type stuff
or whether it's, for example,
climate change, right?
They're gonna say, well, no,
you don't have a right to
be over there doing that,
and they're gonna try to
shut down our way of life
and kind of export, frankly,
their misery to the rest of us.
- I left that misery.
I don't want that imported.
- And, you know, look,
one thing I do
believe in, though,
is that there's an ebb
and flow to things.
I do believe in
the power of ideas.
I believe in the
power of freedom.
I believe in the power of
the fundamental principles
upon which this
country has founded,
and that leaders of this
country have an obligation
to project confidence
in those principles
and go fight for them.
You know, I was talking
to a group this morning,
and all these folks that
get June 6th and D-Day
and they talk about their dads
or granddads and their family
that were storming the
beaches of Normandy
to a wall of bullets.
And they talk about Washington
crossing the Delaware
and Texas, the
guys on the Alamo.
And you know, I say,
"Oh, you're talking
about all that pride."
And then they go,
"Man, you were real courageous
in that speaker's fight,
'cause they were tweeting
mean things about you."
It's like, look, come on guys.
You wanna fight for freedom?
Just get out there and
say what you believe.
Stand up like I did at a
Chamber of Commerce event today
and say DEI is garbage.
Stop promoting it.
It's hurting our recruiting
at the Department of Defense.
We've just gotta
start being honest,
because I think people want it.
And I think DeSantis
shows that in Florida.
He wins by a million
and a half votes.
62% of Hispanics,
50% of single women.
Why? 'Cause he led.
He wasn't afraid of Disney.
He isn't afraid of
the universities.
He isn't afraid to take
on the establishment
and take on all this woke stuff.
He wasn't afraid to
send a shipment of folks
to Martha's Vineyard, and
then he won 62% of Hispanics.
People are tired of people
who are trying to
buy their votes.
They want them to lead.
- People always forget the
guy only won by 30,000 votes
over a meth addict
before, so it's like,
this is a big change, yeah.
- You know, I do
wish the blue states
would leave the red
states well enough alone.
And I hear the mean things
they say on Twitter, right?
But one of the things
they go back to is,
oh, Kentucky's a welfare state.
Well, the Democrats are
the ones who are voting,
number one, to send
the money to Kentucky,
and their war on poverty
has hollowed out Appalachia.
- Failed.
- Thank you very much.
You're on your fourth generation
of destroying our culture,
so I'd prefer you just take
your welfare or whatever.
I don't vote for it,
and I also remind them we
just printed $5 trillion.
The government is spending money
that the states didn't send it,
that the people didn't send it.
We've got 50 welfare
states at the moment.
Let's end the welfare
state for everybody.
- All right, unfortunately,
we only got about
three minutes left,
and I'd definitely love
to have both you on
for a proper sit down
when we have more time.
- Let's do it.
- But you mentioned DeSantis.
I saw you guys a couple weeks
ago at this blueprint event
that he's trying to
really give the states,
this is the plan
to fix everything.
It seems like this
Trump/DeSantis fight is coming.
You jumped in early.
DeSantis has not even said
he's running for president,
unless something happened in
the last 20 minutes or so,
but you endorsed him already.
What was your
calculation on that?
- Yeah, look, I think
primaries are healthy.
I was Senator Cruz's
chief of staff.
It was healthy in 2016,
but nobody gets anointed
in this country.
I don't care if you're Ted
Cruz who came in second,
or if you're President
Trump, who was President.
Ron DeSantis, just 'cause
you're strong in Florida,
nobody gets anointed.
You gotta run.
So I support Governor DeSantis.
I'm not afraid of that.
He's a good man.
I've known him for a decade.
He's done amazing
things in Florida.
We've already talked about it.
I think we need to
have a robust debate
about where we want to
carry this country forward.
I would like to have someone
who can serve for eight years.
I'd like to have somebody
who's not a baby boomer.
who has a proven track
record of conservatism,
so that's where I am.
- You might get some
mean tweets, you know?
- Eh, it's all good.
- So I like both candidates,
but let's be honest.
Ron DeSantis was at
the tip of the spear
on fighting back
against COVID tyranny.
If we'd had somebody like
that in the White House
who fired Fauci and Birx
instead of giving
them commendations
for their great jobs.
- You tweeted out
a heck of a video
of Trump kind of bungling
things related to Fauci.
- Well, I mean, there
was a lot of fear.
You know, the people understand
that the former President
Trump hired a lot of people
that should have been fired,
and we thought he would've
fired them, but he didn't.
And so, I haven't waded
into the race yet,
but I will say,
Governor Ron DeSantis,
the best governor in
the United States.
There's no close second.
And I had the privilege
of serving with him
for six years in the
House of Representatives,
and people can go back
and look at those votes
if they want to know where
he stands on federal issues.
He's a very strong conservative.
- I'm gonna pull
a Joe Biden here.
You just waded into the debate.
It was a pleasure, guys.
Thank you very much.
- Hey, thanks, Dave.
- Thanks, Dave.
- Thanks.
- Yeah, God bless.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.